Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I am your host, Rawkode. Today, we
are gonna be taking a look at Policy
Reporter.
It is an open source software for hooking
up the policy reports from Kivernal to other
pieces of other
pieces of software to your monitoring systems so
that you can get better visibility into the
policy violations and audits within your cluster.
Before we get started, this is a little
bit of housekeeping.
So first, please, subscribe
to the YouTube channel and click the bell.
This just means that you will get notifications
on future episodes of Rawkode live as well
as helping other people discover this content as
well.
There's also a Discord server. Feel free to
join in there and bring all of your
questions. We are active pretty much around the
clock at the moment. So, you know, even
if I'm not streaming live, there's still lots
to learn and share with other people.
And lastly,
I wanna thank my employer, Equinix Medal. They
provide the time and resources that I get
to invest in their shows and produce
cloud native learning materials so that we can
all learn together.
So thank you very much Equinix Medal. Feel
free to check it out. There is a
quote there for 50 US dollars. This is
around one hundred hours of compute of bare
metal clouds. Lots of fun to be had.
Enjoy it wisely.
Okay. So we're gonna take a look at
Policy Reporter, and today, I am joined by
its creator,
Frank Jobolete. Hey, Frank. How are you?
Hi, everyone.
Frank's fine. And you? Yes.
I'm very well. I'm very excited to kinda
take a look at Policy Reporter today, and
I'm really happy that you were able to
join me.
Yeah. Thanks for having me. Yeah. Do you
wanna just start with a little bit of
a introduction to yourself, and then we'll talk
about Policy Reporter just after.
Sure. I'm
Frank
in
German.
Frank j in the, yeah, communities
because it's much easier to say.
Yeah. How I say, I'm from Germany,
from the New York Dresden.
I'm working as software developer for Move Elevator.
We are a
company creating
custom applications
for our clients,
mainly with PHP,
Vue. Js, and, yeah, the old, good web
stack.
And, yeah, I started with
Kubernetes and the cloud stuff
for a year,
And I really like the community. It's
very cool to work with other people.
And so I'm today part of the Fackle
community
as well as Hiverno.
And, yeah, I'm
in the Rawkode chat every day
as well as the CNCN show.
Awesome. Thank you very much for sharing that
with us.
So
today, we're taking a look at
policy policy reporter. I I was gonna say
your latest open source project, but I don't
know like how many of these you just
have lying around. But Policy Reporter is is
a really cool project that we've been talking
about a lot on a Discord server and
you you're shipping updates so fast
that it's just amazing to watch that evolve
over time.
But why don't we take it back a
little bit and you just tell us, like,
what
is the primary responsibility of your project policy
reporter?
The main goal is to get a better
visibility of
what happens with your Kiverno policies.
So
I use Kiverno
to
enforce more best practices.
But it's really hard
to enforce everything
because a developer's stuck. They have no no
not much experience with Kubernetes. They don't know
how to do things. So I thought it's
better to audit these violations
and have, in the later point in time,
a look at it.
But, yeah, this was not that easy
because you only have this CLE
CRD
commands to see what's going wrong.
Then it's across the complete cluster with many
different namespaces.
And, yeah, it's
was not that easy. And so I
thought it's a good idea to create a
tool for this. I'm
part of a FARGO community. In FARGO, we
have a tool called FARGO Sidekick.
And FARGO Sidekick UI,
it's very similar.
You have a UI where your violations from
Fireco are displayed. You have a table to
filter, sort, and so on.
And, yeah, I translate this into Kaverner. And
so Policy Reporter was born.
Awesome.
So I think that's a really
common story that, you know, I hear when
I'm speaking to people in the cloud native
ecosystem is that they want to adopt, you
know, tools like Kiverrnal and open policy agent
and all of these best practices.
But at the same time,
you know, the platform teams and the SRE
teams want their developers to be as productive
as possible, especially with learning all of these
new technologies as well. So moving and having
policies run-in audit mode rather than force mode,
I think is is extremely common. I think
what you articulated well there is that you
you gotta do something with those audit logs,
and that's where Policy Reporter comes in. It
gives us the ability to hook it up
to our existing tooling like Prometheus and Loki,
and we'll take a look at this on
the hands on bit. But
just making sure that they're not lost in
the abyss, the noise or the migrations or
all those other things that we have surrounded
us all the time. So very,
very We
have a question now from Carlos.
Carlos is curious of how does this compare
to other solutions that are pros and cons?
Is there anything similar to Policy Reporter out
there at the moment?
I don't know other tools for Kivera, especially.
I don't know if there is anything else
in the OPA community.
I'm not sure about the products from the
as a company behind.
I think if so, the main difference would
be that it's not a platform or any
byte solution. It's
open source tool to install, to debug your
policies. You can try what is affected.
And if you don't need it anymore because
you're in a production environment,
you can remove it easily.
So,
yeah, it's a small small application, I think.
Okay. Let's touch on one of other Carlos's
questions just before we we kinda move on
a little bit here. So Carlos says, they're
a little confused. Is it Falco versus Kiverna?
I'm gonna assume you would run both, but
do you wanna just give me your thoughts
on that?
Yeah. I'm running both.
Security in Kubernetes has more than one layer.
You have runtime things. You have
money manifest validation.
And, yeah, Faggle is security
at runtime.
It tracks if
you SSH in a node.
If you change a file in a it's
a c it
its directory
or in the root system,
it affects all this this time on runtime.
And, yeah, you can
also
alert
track
track or alerts and other applications.
But Kavana is for static validation, I think.
So more you
if you have resources defined in your manifest,
if you don't use latest, all these
things,
it's related to
port security policies where you
try to remove
host paths, host ports, these things. So it's
another level of security, I think. It's Oh,
yes. Best differentiation.
Yeah. I couldn't agree more. I think Falco
fits into that space. Like you said, runtime
security is monitoring syscalls
on the kernel and alerting you when things
are doing things that you maybe don't want
them to do.
Kiverrno and open policy agent on the other
side, they're taking a look more at the
declaration or the manifest that we're applying to
our cluster and making sure that they conform
to the constraints that we apply as well.
And we'll see that, you know, we've we've
got, well,
not a cluster. I have a Docker for
Mac, which has got a Kubernetes API where
I have deployed Kiverno.
I think what we can we can do
to start with is maybe just take a
look at the pod security policy replacement policies
from Kiverrno.
I can't remember if it ships with a
default report, but maybe we can look at
that and and actually see the problem. Right?
Is that Kiverrno does expose some of this
information, but not in a way that is
consumable
by other tooling. And then then we can
move move into Policy Reporter. How does that
sound to you, Frank? Yep. Makes sense. Awesome.
Alright. Let's
get my screen share up. So for anyone
who wants to follow along or is watching
this not in real time, you can find
Policy Reporter,
Frank's GitHub
username
slash policy dash reporter.
Nice.
Now what if I go prepared upfront?
Very, very little. I have Docker for Mac
running. I have deployed Kiverno.
I've got Kip Prometheus deployed as per Frank's
request. Oh, no. My note export is broken.
Although that probably wouldn't work in Docker for
Mac, so that's okay.
Which gives us a Prometheus operator, a Grafana,
and a Prometheus instance.
So pretty much all the tools that we
wanna kinda hook into and and show what's
happening. So
what's the best way for someone new to
Policy Reporter to get started? Do you want
me to pop open the docs, or do
you wanna just go off script? What what
are you thinking?
I think the easiest thought is with the
policy report UI.
It's
yeah. You
add the repo as available as hand chart,
so it's
very easy to install it.
Then,
yeah, you have this basic installation be but
this is only the metrics for Grafana, so
you need an existing monitoring to use this.
So the, yeah, way easier part would be
the second installation where you enable
the UI and have a standalone UI UI
where you can start from.
Okay. So I can just copy and paste
this helm install command that sets the value
to true for the UI deployment, and I'm
still gonna get the Prometheus exposition. Is is
that correct?
Yeah. You the the parameters metrics are default,
so they're always enabled.
With the UI enabled, you get a second
application's UI. So it's not backed into the
Policy Reporter. It's
standalone
application which works over a REST API policy
reporter.
And
you can access UI over
port forward.
Alright. Perfect. Okay. So I've added your Helm
repository.
I'm now doing the Policy Reporter installation
with the UI enabled,
and then I'm gonna copy and paste the
port forward,
which I'm assuming is just gonna take me
straight in to the UI if I knew
how to copy and paste. There we go.
Yeah.
Alright. So okay. So it's just pulling some
images right now. We'll give that just a
few seconds
We'll get started.
Let's see.
Why are you pending?
Oh, no. There we go.
Just me being impatient. So this is pro
forward into 8082.
Ta da.
Easy. Yeah.
Love it I love it when things are
just, you know,
helm repository at helm install. Like, job is
done. There you go. There's your next UI.
Oh, look at material and shiny. Very, very
cool.
Hamstrap reduce reduce
the effort to get started because it's, you
know, has all this default
URLs,
ports, and so on. So it's all configured
for you behind.
And, yeah, you see your first violations
for the monitoring
ports because, you know,
they has host paths and
host namespace configured,
which is not allowed with the PSP
policy no.
Pod security policies, so to say.
Okay. So
an issue I what I'm seeing is just
how many policy violations we have. We've got
a kind of graph here. So I'm assuming
if we fix any of these, if we
can fix any of them, we'll start to
see this drop. We've got failing cluster policies.
Yeah. What's the difference here? Is that
The the dashboard is a overlook
of failing resources,
so you don't see any passes because it's
a, you know, short introduction.
And the main diff or the the only
difference besides
policy report and the cluster policy report is
that the cluster policy report
is only for resources that are cluster scoped,
like namespaces.
Got it. So they have its own CID
in Kiverno and also in the
policy report standard.
And so it's a yeah. It's different.
Okay. So should I click on policy reports?
Should I click on one of these things?
What do wanna look at?
Yeah. If you click on any of these
labels, it's only a filter for the table.
So you have a search field so you
can easily
filter for a specific
policy or rule or severity if supported.
And I think you can go to the
policy reports. There is a more detailed use
only for the policy
report CID.
So
at first, you don't see any violations
because you have a default filter for a
single policy
at the beginning.
But you can
open this select field, and you should have
option for all policies.
So you can
define what you were looking for if you
would like to see any violations
or for a single policy or for a
set of policies.
And if you like, you have also a
optional
filter on the right side for only a
namespace. So you can also recreate the view
of a single report for a single namespace
if you like.
It's Yeah.
On you.
I I think I prefer looking at the
sea of green passes rather than my three
failing policies.
At at least we can see here what
what's happening and how the policies are being
used and consumed, which is
I think just
exposing more of this information in an official
way is really important for people to understand
what is happening and and just get more
comfortable using tools like this.
Yeah.
Standard for policy reports has two more status
codes, and they also have error and warning.
But at
this time only has passed and failed
violations.
If
our feature future tools also use the CRD
like,
they have this additional status codes, you will
all also see additional tables for status
codes.
So it's high the UI hide automatically
all tables and charts
without any value.
Okay.
So
I just wanna understand then, like, you know,
we've deployed Policy Reporter and the UI. They're
two separate deployments, two separate pieces of software.
Is the Policy Reporter UI just creating Kubernetes
API for
the Kivernal reports,
or is it going through Policy Reporter in
the middle? Like, how how does this actually
work? It's
working with the Policy Reporter together.
Policy Reporter
fetches over the
Kubernetes API the CRDs
and convert them
in the one side into
parameters metrics
and the other side in a custom
structure,
which
also
available as REST API. So the Policy Reporter
has a REST API,
which you can also use with your own
tools. The UI is not required. They are
open and also available endpoint.
And UI use this REST API from the
policy reported UI Policy Reporter
and
has
a proxy
back end because if you put forward your
Policy Reporter UI, you need access to the
API it's fetching from.
So you can only fetch from the
back end from the Policy Reporter UI, and
so you need some API in the middle.
But this API fetches information from the Policy
Reporter and forward it to the UI itself.
Alright. Very cool.
We have a question
from
Walid who is asking, can I monitor the
audited policies
only?
And then a little bit of a follow-up
is, like, audit events not enforced.
Maybe we could just explain the difference between
Kivernal policies with enforced mode and audit mode
and what that actually means as well. You
wanna dive into that?
Sure.
Audit events
don't affect you if you apply any manifests.
It's creating this policy report in the background,
and you can
access this information when anything violates.
If you have an enforced mode,
it blocks you from applying this manifest. So
you
the the kubectl
will return an error with the message
from your policy.
And, yeah, you have to fix the manifest
before you can apply it to a cluster.
Kavura offers
configuration in your policies, the background.
Background has
well, background
is used to
validate existing resources. When you apply a new
policy in an enforced mode, you enforce new
manifests. It has no
don't it's used for existing resources.
So with the background enabled, it also scans
existing resources and creates a report for it.
So if you apply an enforce
policy with the background scan enabled, you also
get the report for this policy, and you
also see the result
for these policies in the UI.
So you can also track the violations for
existing resources.
Okay.
Slight segue then. I'm assuming you run this
in your production Kubernetes environment?
Yeah. How I say I'm
using Kubernetes
in my free time as a hobby project.
We introduced Kubernetes in my company
a few weeks ago and created our
first
playground Kubernetes.
But we don't have any production
applications
running on
cloud services?
Not yet. That day is coming. Not yet.
Yeah. I am working on it.
Yeah. Okay. I'll just I guess, we'll you
know, we can kinda speak hypothetically then. But
I'm I'm gonna assume that it's okay to
have policies that are failing and be aware
of it rather than having policies not enforced
at all. I can imagine, especially maybe in
my own production environments, is it
as the goal to have
zero failing policies, or is it just to
keep that number going down? Do you get
any opinions on that?
I don't think that you have to fix
all issues.
Sometimes you can't really fix it because
maybe it's an application you installed with Helm,
and you don't have access to this
configuration.
Maybe you have tools. They need this
host path, for example Yeah. To work with.
LongHorn
as storage
application
or fleet or something like this. So you
can't fix everything.
I use it as best practices. So it's
good if they pass, but it's not required.
And maybe you create
a policy to get some information about your
environment.
Maybe you want to know which
pod's running with the latest image. So you
can create a policy. You can set to
audit mode, apply it, see the result, and
remove it instantly.
So it's also a tool to get
any information you want from your cluster.
Alright. Thank you.
Okay.
Is there anything else you wanna look at
in the UI before we move on to
other best NPCs?
You can click on locks,
but I don't know if there are no.
Not Yeah. My local cluster may not really
have much going on. Yeah.
It's
the locks are coming when you deploy
violations after the
UI started. So you started the UI right
now. So there was
no new workload, so it didn't work. But
we can also see this maybe later on
when we did some stuff.
Yeah. So we've got some default policies installed.
I'm sure we can definitely violate a couple
of them and see those logs coming in.
Why don't we take a look? You know,
we've got all of this deployed to the
to the cluster
with Prometheus and Grafana. So can we walk
through the process and the steps involved for,
you know, maybe bells on out my own
little dashboard here?
Yeah. To getting started with Grafana.
Yeah. So you said that
policy report are running in the cluster. It
takes all of the policy reports from Kiverno
and produces Prometheus metrics. So I'm assuming the
first thing we wanna do is is make
sure that those are being consumed by the
Prometheus and our our Kubernetes environment. Yes.
Yeah. You
can
when you're running with Prometheus
operator,
you can use optional
monitoring
sub chart of Policy Reporter.
It provides you a service monitor, a CID
for this operator to
scrape the metrics,
and it provides also
configurable
dashboards for Grafana, if you like.
So
to
running the
installed version of your operator,
you have to
I
don't know if
it's good to do it over the CLI.
Maybe the values YAML is
better in this case because we have
to configure a few things.
Yeah. You're right. Okay. So
where is that first one? So we enabled
UI dot enabled. That's all so far. So
why don't we do I think I created
a YAML. There we go.
Oh, that's the Cavernon YAML. Okay. Alright.
So UI
enabled.
True. This is always done so far, I
believe. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
What
this other command you've got here from the
documentation is saying is that we can turn
on monitoring
dot enabled and then provide a
name space.
Yeah.
You need to enable the monitoring.
That's enabled part of the name space.
When you're using this
prometheus operator,
you have to
install the config maps, which include the configuration
for the Grafana dashboards in the same name
space as Grafana.
So that's why you need to declare namespace
where the Grafana lives in.
Okay.
So where is my I think it's just
in monitoring.
Yeah.
So So, yeah. You define it as monitoring.
And
I've got like there.
It's happy now.
Nice.
Is there anything else we should tweak now
before we do an upgrade just so that
we have it available?
Yeah. You have to add a service monitor
label. I think it's
was right over the
commands when you see the description with monitoring
service monitor dot labels.
Yep.
Yeah. This part.
So
I am using Ranger, and Ranger has included
preconfigured
monitoring system,
which is built on top of the
Prometheus operator.
In this case, you don't set this label
because Prometheus
looks over all namespaces.
In this installation,
in this custom installation, you need to declare
a label for the service monitor. So the
Prometheus
resource,
yeah, scrapes the service monitor.
That's why we need to define it in
this case.
Okay. So we need to
define service monitor.
Okay.
So what label is this looking for?
I think the default one would be release
and the name of your
Should I just describe the Prometheus
operator?
Is that?
Yeah.
You need to
describe the Prometheus
resource.
So not the pod,
but the Prometheus
CRD. Ah, yes. Yes. Okay. So let's do
a get Prometheus.
Describe Prometheus,
this one. And there should be a label
on here that we wanna target.
Yes. Service monitor selector on the bottom.
Got it.
Okay.
I'm assuming this is maybe just a map
then rather than a Yeah. Less.
Does the case matter?
I'm not sure, but I think it's lower
case. In my
installation,
I use lower case.
This is pop up.
Yeah. Lowercase.
Weird that it's
capitalized.
Must be something to do with that output.
I'm gonna ignore it for now. But, yeah,
let's go with lowercase.
So
our values fail for the policy reporter deployment
has monitoring enabled. Service monitor should be under
monitoring, not on the same
syntax. Yeah.
See? It's always good to have a second
set of eyes on these things. Okay.
Monitors enabled. We've pointed it to the correct
namespace, and we've added the service monitor from
the Prometheus CRD.
Means
I should be able to do a helm
upgrade
policy reporter policy reporter. We don't need any
of the sets nor the create
thingy,
but I will need the namespace one.
Does that look?
Do you need to set the values, Yandian?
Yes.
Alright.
Yeah.
I think that was okay.
I think this should work. I hope it
will.
We're both just ringing with confidence here, but
we've got revision two, so I'm gonna take
that as a win.
So I'm assuming
at our policy reporter namespace,
we should see
oh, wait. We see I don't see that
it should update the Policy Reporter because it
doesn't change it. You only apply more resources
for the operator. That's right. Because we're deploying
a service
monitor.
Maybe not oh, yeah. There we go. Yeah.
So should
we pop open the Prometheus and see if
we have any metrics?
You can show it in
Prometheus or
later on in
Grafana.
Yeah. Let's take a look at the the
Prometheus first and then
we'll see if we can get well, we
will. Confidence.
We will get Gafana hooked up.
But I always like to test at the
source first. So
in theory,
if we go to target,
I think that's okay. Do we have any
policy?
Hey, look at that. Yep.
Nice.
Which means we should have access to a
graph. There we go.
So
I'm not sure what this search for policy.
Policy.
Yeah. Policy report results, summary.
I'm gonna execute.
And we have loads of metrics.
Awesome. Yeah.
But, of course, we do not encourage people
to use the Prometheus
baked in UI.
This is where Grafana really shines.
That's right. Yeah.
Alright. You mentioned sorry.
On you go. What?
No. Continue.
Okay.
It's just crazy. I mean, you mentioned something
really cool earlier on in the episode is
that there are pre canned dashboards that are
shipped for us. So let's
can I just put forward to Grafana and
we walk through the process again those hooked
up?
Sure. Yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
Port forward.
3,000.
Okay. We have Grafana.
But I'm gonna ask if my dashboard isn't
here already. Right?
They should already
available.
Alright.
Give it a refresh, see if it helps.
Oh, it does not appear happy with me
at all, does it?
Now I have to decide, am I being
impatient
or is it broken?
Let's try
one more time.
Strange. Okay.
So
we have our dashboard home.
Yeah. You should click home on the yeah.
And there you already see policy
reports or label.
So you can also in your list, in
the first entry, yeah,
can click on it and you should get
three dashboards.
So they
all very
similar to the dashboards you saw in the
UI.
So they provide similar informations, but in a
better
scope in Grafana.
So is that something that the Prometheus
the Kube Prometheus project is is doing? How
did you get those Grafana dashboards into my
Grafana?
Yeah. The operator supports
config maps to
define dashboards.
And what I did is I built these
dashboards in my own Grafana and export them.
I replaced
some
informations with
dynamic
variables you can configure in the Helm chart.
So as I said, you have some status
codes like warning and error. They are not
supported yet.
So but I
would like to support the CRD complete.
So I
add them to the dashboards,
but I added
Helm
values
to disable them or hide them in this
case.
And,
yeah, the sub chart includes this config maps
and add them to your Grafana namespace.
And so they picked up from Grafana and
available.
That's a nice a nice touch. I like
that.
Alright. What one do wanna pop open first
then?
Yeah. I think you will see the most
You can do the
third one, the policy reports.
So that's it's a
complete overview as you saw in the UI.
Yeah. You have all tables currently
also without
items.
You can
well,
in
you should see tables with results,
but maybe
not.
Yeah. I'm not sure. I mean,
if I was oh, there we go. I
was gonna I was gonna say, if I
was better at my job here, then I
would have deployed all of this much earlier
so we had retro data to capture. But
miraculously,
it just popped right on there, so that's
pretty cool.
Well, our confana did take the attempts to
load the homepage. So something tells me there's
a maybe there's something going on with the
communication back to my Docker for Mac.
But but it doesn't matter. It's possible.
Okay. So we got our we can see
how many policies we have failing. We got
the cluster policies. These two very
similar to what were available in the policy
report or UI.
We then actually have some time series here
where we're seeing the count of
failing policies over time grouped by the policy
that had the failure,
which is a very nice one to chart.
I could imagine
in
real production clusters where there's a vast array
of policies being audited and enforced,
that single graph alone is gonna be
really, really interesting for anybody, I would imagine.
Yeah. And that's a graph that I can't
provide in the Policy Reporter UI because then
I need the complete history of all
violations.
So
that's, I think
Yeah. This is classic classic time series now.
Like, you you need a TSDB for it.
You need that available.
That makes a lot of sense.
And then we have a table just down
the bottom. I think it's just showing pretty
much the same thing as the graph.
And we have no cluster policies, so that's
to be expected.
Should we pop open the other two?
You can also see the policy
report details.
Yeah. Cluster policy
don't show anything because we don't have any
cluster policy. So I think we can skip
it. Yep. We got the namespace breakdown,
and we got another little time series graph.
And I think these aren't loading just because
of my whatever's going on with my network.
Yeah. And in this dashboard, you
also see currently the status and the arrows
status
chart without any value.
But if
you dive more into the configuration purpose of
this monitoring chart, you
could be
you could be enable disable this this parts
of the dashboard if you don't need it.
Yeah. I mean, I think this this alone
is
the main reason why everybody running Kivernal and
their clusters just needs to have Policy Reporter
available to it. Like, you know, I think
every
I think it's really safe to see every
operational team out there in the world probably
has a Grafana instance running in their cluster
with Prometheus. Like, they want
again, I'm not gonna put words in everybody's
nose. I want to use the same tooling
across my stack. And I think this is
just really super cool.
Yeah.
Because once I have it all here and
I have my dashboards, you know, the entire
team has visibility into it. But I also
have the ability to then build my alerting
on top of it. There may be some
policies that although I have an audit mode
due to migration issues,
probably wanna notify somebody
quickly.
I mean, I can imagine there are some
that I would deem probably a security risk.
Although, maybe I should just enforce them. I
don't know. I'll talk myself out of that
one at some time.
Yeah. For alerting and notification purposes,
the second main part of the policy reporter,
which was the initial idea behind it
to
send notifications
when any violations happen to
tools like Loki,
Elasticsearch.
It also has support for
Microsoft Teams and Slack.
So,
yeah, only with Policy Reporter and any chat
client you use, you can also
notification
send notifications to it.
Okay. So back and send notifications to Slack
and Discord, I guess, to any HTTP point,
really, as long as I just connect it
up.
Yeah. And if your chat client is not
available yet, you can,
at any time, create an issue or
develop
it yourself and create a p p effort.
Yeah. I love that. Pill request welcome always.
Yeah.
Is there anything else you would like to
to show if I forgotten anything?
One
part
which we don't cover because it's only related
to this notification
things are
priorities.
So for
Loki,
I created,
yeah, a priority
to violations
because
the policies
pass or fail. So if you have a
failed one,
maybe you differentiate
between that's not that important, that's very important,
that's disaster.
And
so
I
integrated a mechanism
to define
what's
how important your policy is.
Per default, you create
it creates a priority of warning
for a policy.
But you have
the possibility
also over the helm chart to create a
mapping between
policy name and the priority.
And so you can
switch between a info policy,
running policy, critical policy.
You have a special key for a default.
So if you like to
default all
policies to info,
you can also do that
with one configuration
and, yeah,
configure how you like it.
And in Loki, you have different
colors and, yeah, your alerting tools will stick
on these priorities.
Oh, nice. Very cool feature.
I
opened an issue and also a PR to
Kiverno for
configure
severity to policies,
which is
CRD way currently to
define
between low, medium, and high.
And if
this feature will be available in Kiverno, it
use this information also to map your priority
between
info, warning, and critical.
So you get two ways, the Policy Reporter
way and the more native
Policy Calverno
way.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. So
you said you've opened that as your conversations
are happening, and maybe that's something we'll see
in a a future release of Caverno. Right?
Yeah. It's
scheduled for
January,
I think.
Sweet. Awesome.
So what's next for Policy Reporter then? Do
you have any other, you know,
features, ideas, pencils, under your head that you're
you're gonna bring to us soon?
At first, I have a look if any
other tools will implement the CRDs,
like,
already mentioned. And if so,
have a look if it worked as expected
or if there are any differences I have
to
change in the Policy Reporter to also work
with these tools.
The second part will be more Kiverno specific.
Currently, Kiverno
works on
its own metrics with more informations I can
provide because they yeah. Kyverno internal.
And
if they will be available,
I want to integrate them into the UI
as as
module, I think.
So you don't only have the CRD
global
metrics,
but also
more detailed one for specific tools that work
with the CRDs.
But this this depends
on the metrics for Kaverno and when they
are available and so on.
But I will have a look, an eye
on it. So
k.
Alright. Is there anything else you want to
cover before I let you get back to
your day?
I
would say thank you
also to
the Rawkode community
because the idea was born also in an
episode with you and the team.
Yeah.
I really thank the
community
for supporting me by
answer questions,
help me with policies, and so on.
And, yeah, also Adrian and the CNCN community
who also helped me a lot and promoted
my small
first version of Reporter in its
show.
Yeah. I think that's one of the the
great things about the communities that, you know,
we're working with here, the cloud native and
Kubernetes and policies and. Like, we all just
want each other to succeed, and the amount
of support across the board I think is
phenomenal
and always welcome to And
I'll just say thank you to you. You
know, you're the one that has invested your
time and energy into giving us better tooling
to get those really critical metrics out of
Kiverno and to those tools we're familiar with
and you're even going above and beyond to
provide like your own UI and stuff like
that. So thank you very much, Frank. It's
a really cool project and I I hope
a lot more people will check it out
and make their lives that little bit better.
I hope so. Thank you very much for
having me. Alright. Well, you have a great
day. Thanks. I'll speak to you at the
Discord. Everyone else, I'll speak to you soon.
Yeah. Thank you everyone for watching.
Bye. Bye.
Bye.